the jurgen experience anyone defending
institutional wall street right now
got an envelope with photos of
themselves at jeffrey epstein's birthday
so what's what jamie's just pulled up
with that and what tim was talking about
is this
insane situation that's happening it
started out with game stop
on with with these these intelligent
vipers from reddit
decided they were going to figure out
well what what they
here's the thing wall street speculation
and these people
that have been these hedge fund guys
they've been manipulating the stock
market in a very similar way forever
yeah
but these guys on reddit decided to get
together collectively
and what is it called the the subreddit
called wall street bets
so wall street bets decided that
these hedge funds were shorting game
stop
right so they decided we're gonna buy
games that we're gonna [ __ ] their whole
system up just to boost
game stuff yes well just to see if they
could and just they get
it's fun it's fun so the a bunch of
people bought
game stop stock game stop stock
rose higher than it's ever risen in the
entire history of the company
i think it was up 11 000 percent is that
the case
uh the actual percentage yeah i don't
know i i might have made that number up
sounded good though didn't it yeah i
mean yeah
it had never been higher than 50 60
bucks and
it shot up to three to four hundred
dollars at some point yesterday which is
crazy a little bit which is
which it's great that's a crazy jump for
no reason
and it was all because of these guys so
this is where it gets complicated
because now regulars do me a favor and
go to
sauger uh his uh instagram page because
he gave me permission to play this today
because he
he just talks about how this is really
exposing the actual corruption in the
stock market and real market
manipulation
because they're trying to do something
about the fact that these wall street
guys are getting [ __ ] over and
like hedge funds have lost billions of
dollars because
and so but the thing is that now that
these guys yeah let's play it
let's play it real quick this is the one
you sent me yesterday right no
one yes the one from today
um let me um i'll send it to regulate
and reform
uh perhaps
let's say all right sagar what's on your
radar well i have a confession to make
this is the first story that's excited
me in a long time
covering the pandemic and trump and stop
the steel
and capital riots and the biden
presidency
it's been a real bummer and i have not
felt a pep in my step like this
in many months and it is now thanks to a
bunch of redditors
going after the people i despise the
most in our society
speculators on wall street by now i'm
sure that you're all familiar with the
story
hedge funds and billionaires took out a
massive short position
on the company called gamestock a band
of redditors on a subreddit called wall
street bets
called their bluff drove the stock up to
the tune
of thousands of percentile more to force
those hedge funds
to liquidate billions of dollars in
losses while the merry band of redditors
gets rich it's the ultimate david and
goliath story
underemployed and unemployed sitting at
home in their pajamas
using the power of the internet and new
trading platforms like robin hood
to destroy the kings of american finance
we are never going to go back to the old
ways of doing business
and wall street knows this so what's
their solution
it's one that we my friends must resist
absolutely at all costs
now they know that they do not have a
monopoly on manipulating the market
they are gonna do everything in their
power to go after you
and people like me who are not on the
side of the billionaire elite
as i laid out yesterday they are already
going into overdrive on cnbc
who started off yesterday by inviting
the literal ceo of the nasdaq on
to call for more regulation let's take a
listen to that again
one of the things that we're talking
about is maybe misinformation and
and pump and dumps and it's occurring on
social media again it's just
i'm wondering whether it's part of the
same problem the type of regulation that
that that we finally need to to consider
and
like i said we should always have a
light touch with regulation but
you're seeing the way things can get
started again this is different maybe
it's reddit maybe it's not facebook but
you're seeing
the the the same situation at this point
it's not about an election
it's not about a well he's also pause
for a second pause for a second
he's also calling for regulation yes
they never call for regulations ever
he's super souls like him the last thing
that guy wants yeah
in terms of like being able to
manipulate the market and make as much
money as possible it's [ __ ]
regulation
so he's calling for regulation is kind
of hilarious and him
saying that they're manipulating it with
social media like
this is literally what they do yep it's
what they do
yeah yeah keep going
name there are interesting things
happening that seem to be spawned to
some extent or at least
at least blown out of proportion by
social media
again adina well i i do think though
that as we look at these new
technologies that are there available to
everyone including investors i i think
it's also important for
regulators to understand that you know
manipulation is manipulation whether
it's happening
through a new technology medium or it's
happening through traditional mail
i think it's just a matter of making
sure that we understand what the
behavior is
what's underpinning the behavior and
working appropriately with the
regulators to
to uh to manage the situation she looks
like a female version of the blind
scientist from contact with jody foster
tell me she doesn't pull up an image of
that guy
all these people on the on the on this
clip have issues
he has richard ramirez teeth it's a
nightmare contact
contact with jody foster go to images
back the guy in the far right yeah oh a
little bit
come on give me that picture yeah i'll
give you that
come on right there yeah go back to her
no they look pretty [ __ ] similar
yeah i get called good reference
almost identical it's so crazy it's the
cheekbones in the mouth are you sure
that's not him
or her i don't mean to dead name or
misgender
okay keep playing it working
appropriately with the regulators to
to uh to manage the situation yeah you
heard that correctly
the guy from cnbc who hates regulation
is now calling for more regulation
and the ceo of the head of one of the
largest trading exchanges
in the world is agreeing with him notice
when hedge funds manipulate markets
when they screw over regular people in
different companies
when wall street requires billions of
dollars in bailouts and floats from the
federal reserve
there isn't any call for more regulation
but a couple of average joes on the
internet
make money at the expense of a
billionaire hedge fund
well that just can't stand and i'm not
exaggerating here just showing you one
clip
the idea across the american elite right
now is that what has happened with
gamestop
is unacceptable don't believe me check
this out
as gamestop and other stocks soared
arthur levitt jr he decided to weigh in
and if you don't know who that is it's
the former sec chairman
who literally presided over the dot-com
bubble
and was appointed by bill clinton who
perhaps more than any president
is responsible for much of the
financialization of our economy
beginning in his administration levitt
wrote an op-ed in bloomberg
calling for a full agency investigation
into online stock trading platforms
and said that social media is taking
advantage of users behavioral psychology
and pushing them into dangerous
territory okay
maybe i don't even really disagree with
that but doesn't it just tell you
everything that this is what they want
to investigate now
that this is what they want the
government to do something about now
don't underestimate how mainstream this
view is yesterday the white house press
secretary said janet yellen
is quote monitoring the situation
elizabeth warren tweeted out that we
needed more regulation
the state securities regulator for the
state of massachusetts
said gamestop trading should be halted
for 30 days
and the sec now says they're working
with regulators
to assess the situation review the
activities and
other participants like i said hey
maybe that's justified but you people
are silent
on the crimes of the actually
influential people who
rig our economy on a daily basis you
want a near perfect corollary
billionaire investor bill ackman he went
on cnbc in march 2020
to give an emotional interview to say
hell is coming
and that hotel stocks would go to zero
his interview
sparked a panic sell on wall street it
is seen in retrospect
as one of the precipitating events of
that drop
guess what at the exact same time right
after that interview
ackman was buying billions of dollars in
the stock
as it hit rock bottom in fact
2 billion in bets against the market as
it was crashing
okay let's pause it it was a crap
there's gonna building there man
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience